النجم المصري محمد صلاح دائما يعود وبعد
فصول الانتقاد والتوبيخ من قبل الصحافه
والجمهور يعود اصنع التاريخ فالفرعون
المصري كما يلقبه جمهور ليفربول يواصل
تحطيم الارقام القياسيه صلاح الذي يتحدى
الانتقادات التي لاحقته هذا العام ضرب
موعدا جديدا مع التالق خلال مباراه فريقه
الاخيره امام مانشستر يونايتد مسجلا هدفين
من اصل سبعه حققها ليفربول خلال المباراه
النجم المصري تجاوز الهداف التاريخي لنادي
ليفربول
ومحققا 129 هدفا في مسيرته المستمره ليكون
حديث الساعه في الصحافه الانجليزيه اليوم
ندخل حياه محمد صلاح ونتعرف اكثر عن سر
تالق النجم المصري الذي سيكون شخصيه
الاسبوع في صباح العربيه بعد تفاصيل حياه
صلاح بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
قبل اعوام كان من المستبعد ربما التفكير
في ان يكون الهداف التاريخي لفريق ليفربول
الانجليزي من جنسيه عربيه لكن محمد صلاح
استطاع كسر المالوف ونجح في ان يحقق ذلك
وبعيدا عن صلاح اللاعب فان حياه النجم
المصريه الخاصه تبدو بسيطه للغايه بالنسبه
لغذاء محمد صلاح فانه لا يؤمن بفكره
الحميه والرجيم للحفاظ على نياقته وبدلا
من ذلك فانه يعتمد على نظام غذائي متوازن
بعيدا عن السكر بشكل شبه كامل على عكس
الكثير من لاعبي الفرق الذين يفضلون ان
يعيشوا قريبا من ناديها فضل صلاح العيش في
مدينه مانشستر يونايتد على بعد نحو ساعه
من ناديه ليفربول مع عائلته المكونه من
زوجه وطفلتين وبعيدا عن كره القدم يحب
صلاح العديد من الرياضات منها تجديف الصيد
وتنس كذلك الجري وركوب دراجات حيث شوهد
الاجازاته الصيفيه وهو يمارس هذه الالعاب
بحسب صحيفه تايمز فان صلاح يمتلك شركه
الاستثمارات العقاريه ام او اس ويل ستيت
وشركه اخرى للاجارات العقاريه وهي
فضلا عن مصنع للاسمنت وتقدر ثروه محمد
صلاح بحسب فورد باكثر من 90 مليون دولار
امريكي
[موسيقى]
ونناقش معكم هذا الملف الرياضي معنى هنا
في الاستوديو الصحفي رياض محمد حامد يسعد
صباحك يا محمد
وعشاق صلاح وحتى منتقدي صلاح
احنا دائما نقعد هناك صحيح متعودين عليك
صحيح شكرا للاستضافه في كل الاحوال اكيد
طب اليوم يا استاذ محمد خلينا نبلش
بالامور الايجابيه اليوم لما بنحكي عن
محمد صلاح واللي اصبح كانه ظاهره وين ما
بتروح تسمع محمد صلاح محمد صلاح بماذا
يتميز محمد صلاح هل نحكي عن مهاره عن سرعه
ام الاثنين معا بنحكي عن اساسي مفهوم
اساسي ان في لاعب عربي اخترق دائره
العالميه يعني بالنسبه لنا بالنسبه
لاجيالنا وحتى الاجيال الاصغر كانت
المساله شاشه تلفزيون مطله من خلالها على
الكره العالميه في حواجز لا نحن بمجرد
التواجد صحيح في نجوم عرب كتير قدموا
ابداعات في الملاعب العالميه ولكن صلاح
راح لنقطه لم يسبقه اليها في رابح ماجر في
غيره في بعض الزاكي نستطيع ان نذكر العديد
من الامثله ولكن اللي وصل له محمد صلاح
غير عادي هذه نقطه نقطه اخرى هو صلاح
بيعطي امل لملايين الشباب وملايين الاطفال
يعني العالميه ليست بهذه الصعوبه هي صعبه
على مستوى ان يكون عندك عقليه معينه تضحي
باشياء معينه ولكن وي نستطيع من هذا
المفهوم اصبح صلاح حديث الجميع يعني حتى
مثلا هيك لما تكون ماشي مثلا بالشوارع
بريطانيا انه لما بتسمع مو صلاح مو صلاح
صحي
بتشخر انك عربي يعني لما نقل هذه المساله
الى العالميه طب خلينا نروح لمنتقدين محمد
صلاح اليوم هل محقين هل هم محقون في نقاط
معينه وبماذا اخطاوا مثلا في تقييم محمد
صلاح
الانتقاد حق لاي احد ولكن عليك ان تنتقدي
وتعطيني مبرر للانتقاد ليس انتقاد من اجل
الانتقاد في عده اسباب انا الحقيقه
استوقفني هذا الموضوع لاننا من عشاق صلاح
يعني خليني اتكلم بمنتهى الصراحه لانه
بشوفه
تاثيره يتجاوز كره القدم مساله الانتقادات
سببها الاساسي هي عده اسباب الاساسي اننا
نفقد فكره الانبهار بالنجم او بالمبدع بعد
فتره معينه ببتدي اقلب ادوار اشوف له
ثغرات في كل مجال نتفق على هذا
تاني نقطه مهمه بالنسبه
يعني
يدوروا على هاي الثغره انا انا فاهم انت
تقصدي يعني
فكره عطاهم صلاح يعيش ثقافه مختلفه يعيش
اجواء مختلفه لازم يكون عنده درجه غير
عاديه من التوازن لانه على المستوى العربي
وعلى مستوى منطقتنا كل شخص داخله ان صلاح
يمثله يعني لازم يكون عنده درجه من
الانضباط بشكل معين درجه من الالتزام بشكل
معين مش عايزين نفوت في تفاصيل صغيره يعني
احنا بنتكلم في كل شيء لكن مثلا مساله
شجره الكريسماس انا واثق ان نفس الشخص
اللي انتقده على شجره الكريسماس كان
المغرب في مول بيتصور وراه شجره كريسماس
هي مناسبه اجتماعيه يعني ما المشكله
ليفربول نفسه بعد ايام سوف يبارك لكل
المسلمين العالم بشهر رمضان اين انت يا من
التقت شجره الكريسماس وفكره التواصل من
فكره التسامح اللي هي فكره اساسيه في
العالم اليوم يعني ليس لدينا طريق سوى
فكره التواصل والتسامح كره القدم وعن طريق
لاعب مثل محمد صلاح هو جسر محمد صلاح سجل
في اوروبا 232
هدف رقم مذهل ب 232 سجده لماذا لم تصفه
الصحافه الغربيه بانه مثلا متطرف او كذا
على حسب الفكره الشائعه بطريقه ما احترموه
واحترموه ثقافته واحترموا ديانته واحترمه
توازنه اكمللي الجزئيه بسيطه
صلاح حينما وصل هذا المستوى في قطاع من
الجمهور العربي تعامل معاه كلعب كره وليس
لاعب عربي خلاص خلينا نصنفه كلاعب كره قدم
وننسى العاطفه فهناك المدريدي هناك
البرشلونه هناك من يشجع انديه اخرى لا
يهمه ان يتقدم صلاه مجرد ان تحدث محمد
صلاح بقدر من الطموح لدينا فار او لدينا
لدينا مباراه مع ريال مدريد نريد ان
نحسمها لمصلحتنا ردا على مباراه سابقه
الدنيا قامت ولم تقعد على المستوى العربي
الجمهوريه المدريد لان جمهوريه ريال مدريد
قوه كبيره جدا فانا استطيع ان اتفهم كل
هذه الجوانب محمد كمان محمد صلاح يعني
للمفارقه فضل انه ما يعيش ليفربول يعيش في
مانشستر هل سيفضل رياضيا البقاء في
ليفربول ام سنشهد مغادره محمد صلاح الى
انديه اخرى
انا يعني ليست هناك معلومات مؤكده عن هذا
الجانب بس اتصور ان الاسطوره انا رايي
يعني الاسطوره يكمل في المكان الذي ابدع
فيه يعني مساله الوفاء للجمهور الذي منعك
كل هذه المكانه مساله ارتياحك انت شخصيا
يعني حتى احنا على مستوى عملنا لما بنكون
مرتاحين في مكان ما بنغيرش التجربه اخرى
يعني اذا انا في مكان وانا ادائي فيه جيد
ومقدر وكل بيئه العمل تقدرني بستمر في هذا
الاطار اتصور انه عنده
وصل في المرحله الحاليه لفكره الحصاد يعني
ست سبع سنوات في ليفربول ان يكون الهداف
في التاريخ ليفربول في البريميرليج ان
يكون الهداف التاريخي في شامبيونز ليج
لديه حتى ارقام جديده سوف يحصدها في
المرحله المقبله واكيد لحديث لا يمل دائما
معك في هذا الخصوص احنا نشكر الجزيل الشكر
الصحفي الرياضي شكرا لك